هولندا تتقدم نحو تحقيق حلمها في الانشاء
امبراطوريتها الخاصه في اوروبا وهذا الامر
يهدد امن روسيا وفق ما كشفت هنا صحيفه
روسيه التي قالت بان الامبراطوريه
البولنديه حلم قديم تطمح اليه وارسو وتسعى
الى تنفيذه من خلال مبادره البحار الثلاثه
التي تضم اثني عشر دوله من شرق اوروبا اما
البحار ثلاثه التي تشكل الشرايين الحيويه
لاوروبا والامبراطوريه البولنديه المزمعه
فهي كما نشاهد هنا بحر البلطيق البحر
الادرياتيكي والبحر الاسود حول بولندا
والتي تمثل
28% من اراضي الاتحاد الاوروبي واثنين
وعشرين بالمئه من حجم سكانها لكنها تسهم
بعشره بالمئه فقط من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي لهذه المنطقه والهدف الرئيسي
لمبادره البحار الثلاثه هو الاقتصاد
اوروبا الشرقيه والوسطى بمستوى اقتصاد
اوروبا الغربيه من خلال تطوير البنيه
التحتيه المشتركه للدول لتعزيز الروابط
الوثيقه بينهما اما مشاهدينا الاهداف
الاخرى التي تتعلق مباشره بالمشروع او ما
يعرف بالمشروع الجيوسياسي هنا من خلال ربط
شمال اوروبا بجنوبها من اجل هزم العدو اي
روسيا في مجال امدادات الطاقه توضح هنا
الصحيفه الروسيه هدف المشروع ايضا انشاء
تدريجي لكتله عسكريه اقتصاديه لبلدان
اوروبا الشرقيه تحديدا حول بولندا
ولتقليص حجم التبعيه لروسيا وتقويض امن
روسيا بموافقه واشراف الجانب الامريكي
التي اذن طبعا ليوارسو بيتم تمثيل المصالح
الامريكيه في المنطقه وهذا طبعا كل هذا
التحليل بحسب الصحيفه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات